gentlemen for the new film don't kill it
which is out now did your distributor
have any kind of demand for how many
dead bodies were in the film I mean
whether they're a body count that you
had to meet no I would that would
actually sort of phrase it more that
they indulged me on that they were kind
enough to not not get in the way that
was certainly a prerequisite for wanting
to do it was you know as how many people
can we kill in a 85-minute running time
so they were very kind to to let me do
it so yeah I think it was they wanted
and no less than 300 was it I think I
think so yes totally it's one of my
favorite things that that you know when
someone I feel like lets me make a movie
because I always feel like you know I'll
say something like okay and so then you
strangle the child and you lift them and
and I'm sort of waiting for like someone
to stop me because in my mind I'm like I
can't that's always a good feeling that
we're on to something good so any other
things that the distributor asked I mean
were there certain scenes I know without
a shirt on or were there are certain
things that they really I mean in all
seriousness no they were very nice
actually they were very easy to work
with it creatively I think you know the
one thing about this project everybody
loved the script and we did a little
drizzle polished on Mike Theatreland I
made it better
just add it on the bar scene in the
beginning and all but know the
distributors were quite good about
everything except they had to be shot in
17 days right it wasn't like Rob Lowe
but so I think you know it was more like
it was financial issues but I think yeah
a creative issue there was nothing
really yeah they were super supportive
very cool was always budgetary you know
you're always you know time is always
the enemy but they were very much on
board night and I was surprised
sometimes you do get producers that want
to impose their will and like but but
they let us make the movie that we
wanted to make which is very rare and I
really thank them for that
I'm wondering too who hired whom because
I know your actor producer and you're
the director so and you were in the
crowdfunding video so who hired whom
well I think I hired myself first
yes exactly I love the script thought it
was good got involved the producers
met with Mike it all happened
concurrently there was as usual with
these independent movies it's not a
simple shot there's like there was also
I'm not a producer who done what side
railed it wasn't part of it in Ryan yet
and but I mean there it was it was like
I met Mike and I'd read the script and I
thought it was great and then I kind of
support the try to support the
filmmakers and you know in their
endeavor and including raising funds for
it it's clear that this is like passion
behind it and that you want it to be a
part of it you know you were in the
IndieGoGo video but I have to take
another sort of turn and that is to stay
in this industry and take a job that you
don't want to do how is that for either
of you and you don't please don't name
projects that you don't want but ones
that you've been a part of that you feel
like you have to keep everyone has to do
certain jobs they don't want to do and
they know that it's part of the Machine
and how is that for the two of you to
know that that's part of being in this
business and staying relevant well again
start then I you know look it's all in
your inner attitude you know you say you
don't want to do it well that's that's
being kind of simplistic about life
because you can always find some good in
any experience even a bad experience
something you think is bad it could be a
good experience you don't even know that
until years later perhaps a weeks later
or days later you know sometimes the bad
things in life where you're being tried
is the things that make you grow so I
mean I look at it that way so say if I
if I need to pay off my divorce for
instance and I need to do a couple of
movies I always try to find some good in
each of those roles even if perhaps if I
were sitting on a pile of money I didn't
have to take that job maybe able to wait
around for something better but you know
what do you think is better
mmm a lot of actors consider I don't
wait for a long time and nothing happens
but a lot of times you can do something
and and out of that energy comes
something that you can't even imagine
you know that's just how life is so
so I just I just take any role I just
try to make the best of it and try to
enjoy it that's how I look at it and
this wasn't one of those pictures just
was one stuff something I wanted to do
but I do stuff you know that sometimes
I'm not 100% sure about but you know
what most of the time afterwards I'm
glad I did it I always think that
because something good always happened
you know so even if you're dreading when
the alarm goes off you you try to find
some kind of gift that maybe you could
learn I'm not dreading it but I you may
be less excited about it but you know
you meet somebody on that set or you
learn something as an actor or there's
some revelation you come to by going
through the hardship that not really
it's part of life that's part of the
experience of of this life you know and
I guess fortunately for me or
unfortunately I'm not sure I don't find
myself in that position too often
because it's not like people offer me
large sums of money to do anything so I
just have to kind of you know find a
project cuz you know these are
low-budget films you're kind of want to
find the the best thing that suits you
the best so when something is a not
particularly a great script that is not
offering you a lot of money and there
are very few perks it's quite easy to
say no thank you for perhaps some other
time so you're kind of just trying to
find the best projects that excite you
and you can find something good about it
and and try to put the best your best
foot forward and trying to make the most
out of it out of those situations but
you know so so kind of like Dolf saying
is always trying to find the the if
there's a silver lining and if there's a
thing then you know then seriously
consider that and try to put your you
know I try to make the best thing out of
it
so Mike according to your IMDB you have
24 credits as an editor 10 as a director
and only six as a writer so it's
surprising to see that you haven't spent
more time writing scripts right I'm just
curious what what the reason is
oh that's a long-winded answer let's see
here so why don't I write script so I
i'd say like when I had my first film in
Sundance
I had a lot of writing opportunities and
they all got rejected you know and I
would have what it sort of Hamill's have
this kind of almost you know reaction
that directing to me I always feel
rewarded
and always good and writing I always
feel rejected and you know I almost feel
that you're like it's it's too much on
you if you write and direct and so at
least and again I don't know maybe this
will change one day I like collaborating
with people you know I just my role as a
director I feel kind of you know also
goes working with the screenwriter the
same way I'd worked with with an actor
or a cinematographer or anything like
that it's it's about collaboration so I
I think part of the the key to being a
decent director is knowing that people
can do the job better than you
and so I feel there's a lot of people
who are better writers than me so why
not collaborate with them and I still
get to put my stamp on it and put you
know what I'd like to do by doing my
polish and working with them without
having all the pressure of like it's all
on me if people hate the script you know
you know or the movie it's all on me you
know and so so I don't know I just sort
of found that that works better for me
working with writers you know so don't
we have a lot of actors that watch our
channel and I know you have a
fascinating story of how you got into
acting but in terms of today 2017 what
would you recommend to someone that
maybe is back home in Sweden or
somewhere else here in the u.s. that
wants to come to LA to be an actor what
would you say to them well I'd say you
follow your dreams you know follow your
instincts so this was that Stella Adler
said in order to be in this business you
need the oh is that the soul of a rose
and the hide of a rhinoceros so that's
kind of sums it all up but you know it's
you know you're trying to protect that
creative part of you by dealing with a
lot of BS every day and and sometimes
you get to express that part of you
that's that you want and the reason
you've got in this business in the first
place so I think people should just
follow their dreams and not be afraid of
failing and trying again in and you know
I mean great actors they look at Morgan
Freeman for instance running into him
not too long ago great guy I mean nobody
knew who he was until he was about 50 55
years old right he'd done all of these
movies and suddenly he was in the
Driving Miss Daisy
so there's a guy who probably had to
deal with a lot of rejection and failure
and know he's you know one of the
greatest actors in the country so in the
world
so you see don't give up that's the main
thing don't give up so if you were gonna
give them a pep talk before they yeah
they came out here because I think a lot
of people come out with the idea
especially if they're told that they're
great looking you know boom or whatever
and then you come here and there's so
many great looking people that it's just
like it's almost overwhelming because
you felt special
maybe yeah it's true it's true I mean LA
is the place everybody comes from the
whole world and I guess you just gotta
believe in yourself and work on your
craft and really basically comes down to
your ability to to entertain people you
know on screen if you if you're in the
film business or a TV business you know
so when you get your shot you got to be
ready to take it and then you got to
really go for it at that point you know
if you know but like I said it's there's
all this time that time in-between which
is tough was it michael caine said you
know they pay me to wait acting i do for
free right so there you go it's a lot of
waiting around
so you just just got to stay at it and
work out and stay healthy and focus on
your craft and go for it when you get a
shot you know you're found that
interesting in terms of being ready when
something's presented and I've heard
that before too that yeah most people
aren't ready they think they are were
there ever times for the two of you
maybe we'll go back to you Mike where
you weren't sure actually am I really
ready when something came your way and
you had to check yourself and say this
is happening and well I mean I think
that could be said it almost with you
know any every project or every film you
know every everything you hope is a new
challenge to yourself and you're trying
something a little different that you
know it's never you know you know yeah
at least for me it's like I can never
just kind of walk through a movie or
just phone it in because there's always
a new challenge and there's always a new
thing I have never worked with a
legendary action hero you know so that
was a thing to like okay how's this
gonna go I had never worked with a giant
CGI spider before it
you know and so you're constantly trying
to find new challenges for yourself and
and you always question you know I mean
at least I feel it's healthy you know
most of my friends are filmmakers and
you know I see the seed in them when a
lot of them get a big opportunity and
they're nervous even though they might
have had a lot of success before they're
nervous and you know what we always kind
of say is like like you know that's good
you know if you're not nervous then I
don't think you're you're in the right
place you know you should be nervous you
should be questioning if you can do it
and the right thing because you know the
ear I think you only progress if you're
kind of put yourself in that
uncomfortable space if you sort of kind
of like no I just like doing this and
I'm gonna do this I do I think you
become complacent I don't think you do
interesting or exciting work so you know
I think it's always important to kind of
you know be out of your comfort zone and
also in your zone add that really you
know it's its life that matters not only
what you do on film on a television
because it's your personal growth
ultimately that's why we were all here
I'm making you do great work and then
you get fat and kill yourself you know
after a few years or commit suicide or
you become a drug addict there and you
can still have great do great work but
you know it wasn't such a great life
maybe for you or for your children or
for your family your friends so you have
to kind of stay close to yourself and
your personal growth while you're trying
to get this other stuff done in the
business and that's kind of that balance
is quite hard to hit and that's I think
work you know I work on that every day
and I think a lot of you know I think
that's one of my strengths perhaps that
I've stayed kind of close to to who I am
who I was before I get in here in this
crazy town you know they think that is
what people have to remember because
that's the big thing that will derail
you failure or success can screw you up
you know it's the middle way like Buddha
says the middle way that's where you
should be most of the time and that's
that's the healthiest way of existing I
think because the big stuff is great but
it always goes away and it can lead to a
lot of negatives and they're really lows
- or tough as well
you understand the middle ground how was
that for you to do the TED talk because
you know you you showed yourself as
human and you're most people all around
the world they see you as superhuman and
so how was that for you because people
do see you they call out your name as
your character Oh Goddard you know yeah
but but you're actually your human being
and yeah you revealed a lot of very
human things yeah
the TED talk yeah I did this mostly
about my dad and my upbringing and the
abuse and things like that and also
trying to help other people by helping
yourself and then your next step is help
other people yeah it was cool I mean it
was it was very emotional and it was
difficult to prepare it was difficult to
get up on stage and you know stand still
and reveal those things and but it felt
really good you know and afterwards you
really feel like a personal
accomplishment that it was to me that's
one of the you know most important
moments for me in my career not and when
movies are great and that's what the
fans see but for me as a person that was
a great moment yeah I'm glad you liked
it Thanks